la civilisation se fait de la dignité de
la personne humaine et de sa liberté si
vous aviez deux ou trois mots pour
caractériser ce que vous appelez la
méthode l'attitude l'art de gouverner
vous diriez quoi tout d'abord
l'indépendance de la nation
ensuite la souveraineté du peuple et
enfin une conception de la france une et
indivisible
appuyez sur la fierté nationale devons
réapprendre à dire non comme disait
malraux seul l'esclave dit toujours oui
c'est ça la réfection dessus du bureau
de chaque responsable politique en
particulier de ceux qui se prétendent
des hommes d'état
[Musique]
le parquet requiert la mise en examen de
quatre policiers mis en cause dans la
ferme et claire détention provisoire
pour trois d'entre eux l'elysée parle je
cite d'une autre hier des dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont manifesté
contre les violences policières partout
en france
[Musique]
les offices religieux de nouveau
autorisé ce dimanche mais toujours
limité à 30 personnes dans les lieux de
culte une mesure contestée par les
fidèles
le conseil d'état demande au
gouvernement de revoir sa copie
à la une de l'actualité cette semaine de
malte rome qui a fait un pas
supplémentaire vers l'acceptation de la
victoire de joe biden il quittera la
maison blanche si le collège électoral
le confirme
la cour suprême de pennsylvanie a rejeté
hier une nouvelle plainte du président
américain
[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue sur rt france à la une
de l'actualité ce dimanche quatre
policiers impliqués dans l'agression
présumée de michel éclair sous le coup
d'une possible mise en examen c'est ce
qu'a réclamé le parquet aujourd'hui
un juge d'instruction a été saisi la
détention provisoire a été requise pour
trois d'entre eux a annoncé le procureur
de paris pour le quatrième placement
sous contrôle judiciaire a été demandée
voyez les précisions de notre reporter
bassin chebbi au tribunal de paris
c'est une conférence de presse qui aura
duré plus de 15 minutes ici au tribunal
de grande instance de paris une
conférence de presse donnée par le
procureur de la république de paris
suite à la nuit du 21 novembre
l'interpellation musclée du producteur
de musique dans son studio dans le 17e
arrondissement le producteur de musique
michel les éclairs suite à cette
intervention musclée quatre policiers
avaient été placés en garde à vue dans
les locaux de l'igpn énormément de
blessures deux plaies ont été révélés à
l'issue de l'examen médical du
producteur de musique le conte le
procureur de la république a annoncé
l'ouverture d'une information judiciaire
je vous propose d'écouter le procureur
de l'accusé
le placement en détention provisoire des
trois premiers policiers a été requis en
considération du trouble exceptionnel et
persistant à l'ordre public provoqué par
la gravité de l'infraction des
circonstances de sa commission et de
l'importance du préjudice qu'elle a
causés et afin d'éviter un risque de
concertation entre les auteurs ou de
pressions sur les témoins
s'agissant du quatrième fonctionnaires
de police auteur présumé du jet de
grenade son placement sous contrôle
judiciaire a été requis avec notamment
une interdiction d'exercer ses fonctions
dans cette affaire la justice
s'attachera à faire toute la lumière sur
ces faits dans le respect des principes
qui les gouvernent
trois policiers en détention provisoire
un autre sous contrôle judiciaire
interdiction d'exercer son métier voilà
ce qui a été déclaré annoncé par le
procureur de la république à l'issue de
cette conférence de presse je vous
rappelle que la sphère est clair et
mêmes
au coeur des différentes manifestations
hier sur la loi sécurité globale cette
affaire est même monté dans les plus
hautes sphères de l'état le président de
la république ainsi que gérald darmanin
le ministre de l'intérieur ont demandé
que la lumière soit faite assez
rapidement sur cette affaire et cette
interpellation musclée du 21 novembre
le producteur de musique tabasser aurait
été contacté par l'entourage des manuels
macron l'elysée a parlé je cite d'une
honte dans la presse aujourd'hui
le directeur général de la police
nationale a fermement condamné ces
violences regarder les policiers doivent
avoir un comportement irréprochable et
c'est le cas de la quasi totalité
d'entre eux ce sont ceux là qui
travaillent de manière professionnelle
honnête responsables qui vont avoir à
subir les conséquences de tels
comportements vous pouvez faire
confiance à la police nationale pour que
ces événements soient traités avec la
plus extrême sévérité une fois les
responsabilités établies en 2020 trente
neuf policiers ont été exclus de la
police nationale 34 en 2019
ces chiffres tordre le cou à la rumeur
d'une police laxiste envers les siens
ont dit notre éditorialiste alexis
poulain en haut lieu à l'elysée on a
paniqué on s'est dit qu'il fallait
absolument que le jugement de cette
affaire soit exemplaire et c'est
clairement ce qui est en train de se
passer on voit le procureur de la
république à faire une conférence de
presse pour parler d'une sanction de
policiers et pas autre chose c'est
inédit dans l'histoire de la prise de
parole du procureur de la république de
cette façon là donc clairement on voit
toute la machine de communication qui se
met en place parce que le politique a
peur et tu vois que finalement là ça va
trop loin et ça pourrait vraiment
remettre en cause toute la façon dont
ont été couverts les exactions et les
violences policières pendant deux ans
lors des manifestations des gilets
jaunes et j'assiste c'est important de
lier les deux la façon dont le silence
médiatique le silence des autorités
la couverture même des autorités avec
les enquête de l'igpn qui ont été
enterrés les unes après les autres
vis-à-vis des mutilés du la répression
du pouvoir je rappelle le nombre de
personnes plus d'une dizaine de
personnes qui ont perdu un oeil qui ont
perdu une main les gens qui ont été
tabassés qui sont en incapacité suite à
des violences policières à l'époque on
n'avait pas le droit de parler de
violences policières
ça a été couvert et aujourd'hui avec
cette affaire michel est clair c'est
comme si tout ça sortait d'un seul coup
et parce que c'est la sphère michel est
clair alors ça devient intolérable
alors non la police ne doit pas être
cette police là il faut changer les
choses
et hier des milliers de personnes ont
manifesté contre les violences
policières partout en france avec des
tensions à paris 62 policiers et
gendarmes ont été blessés les forces de
l'ordre qui ont procédé à 80 eu
d'interpellation des manifestants
mobilisés également contre la loi dite
de sécurité globale
retour sur cette journée baptisée marche
des libertés en images
[Musique]
avec ap
[Applaudissements]
à
or
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et sur le plan sanitaire en france le
conseil d'état donne trois jours au
premier ministre pour revoir sa copie
sur la limitation à 30 personnes dans
les lieux de culte quel que soit leur
taille pour les offices religieux
le chef du gouvernement qui est reçoit
en ce moment les représentants de la
conférence des évêques de france les
catholiques qui célèbrent ce week end le
premier dimanche de l'avent
il est enjoint au premier ministre de
modifier dans un délai de trois jours
les dispositions du décret limitant le
nombre de fidèles à 30 en prenant les
mesures strictement proportionnées
d'encadrement des rassemblements et
réunions dans les établissements de
culte et malgré le retour des offices
dans les églises aujourd'hui les
catholiques se sont de nouveau mobilisés
ce soir on fait le point à paris avec
notre reporter david khalifa regarder un
soulagement pour cette centaine de
fidèles venus prier ici pour cette messe
en plein air place vauban un
rassemblement religieux pour revendiquer
leur droit de culte le conseil d'état a
donné trois jours au gouvernement pour
revoir le décret limitant à 30 personnes
le nombre de fidèles autorisés à
assister aux cérémonies religieuses et
les associations catholiques estime
qu'il s'agit d'une mesure non nécessaire
disproportionnée surtout discriminatoire
la plupart des fidèles qui étaient ici
se sentent tout simplement exclus de
leur église
une colère un qui dure depuis le début
du confinement et le conseil d'état
rappelle d'ailleurs que la liberté de
culte qui comprend la liberté de
participer collectivement à des
cérémonies fait partie est des libertés
fondamentales
chose qu'a rappelé notre micro hugues de
lacoste m référé pour cette mobilisation
religieuse en extérieur je suis saisi
par des gens qui m'expose un problème de
droit et je constate assez vite que il
ya enfin ça m'apparaît en tout cas une
violation d'une liberté fondamentale
qu'est la liberté de manifester il ya
aussi une violation de la liberté de
religion
on considérait que il fallait absolument
contestées chat on avait les moyens de
droit pour le compte est jeté et
d'ailleurs les juges ont fini par nous
donner raison
c'est parce que la liberté de religion
est une liberté fondamentale ce qui veut
dire qu'elle est placée au dessus des
autres libertés que le conseil d'état
peut être saisi en référé liberté quand
les requérants estiment qu'il ya un
texte qui porte atteinte à cette liberté
la belge en a qui a tenu cet office en
extérieur se dit à lui aussi a satisfait
de voir que le conseil d'état leur donne
raison
il était aussi heureux de voir autant de
fidèles venus à s'être réunis ici place
vauban
malgré le froid est la fois un continuer
c'est ce qu'il ya de plus important
selon lui écouter vous attendez
effectivement skis et beaucoup de monde
c'est ce qui est arrivé parce que eh
bien justement tout le monde réclame 7
mai c'est donc le fait qu'elle soit en
plein air ça donne une facilité plus en
plus grande à tous de venir puisque ans
en plein air dehors on n'est pas tenu
par les jolies par la distance donc je
suis très heureux qu'ils aient autant de
monde ce soir c'est une manière de
manifester bien que les catholiques et
français ont encore à la fois vivre au
coeur et qu' ils sont toujours prêts à
tous les combats finalement même s'il
fait froid et et nuit on est toujours là
une messe en plein air significatif du
mal est que ressentent la plupart edéa
catholique en france
et finalement ils contestent avec leur
arme principale c'est-à-dire la foi et
la prière afin de se faire entendre du
gouvernement et pour en parler nous
sommes en direct ce soir avec philippe
haas au délégué diocésain au dialogue
interreligieux pour les questions
politiques et sociétales rattaché à la
basilique de nice
bonjour philippe assauts merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous sur rt france votre
réaction tout d'abord à l'injonction du
conseil d'état qui donne au premier
ministre trois jours pour revoir sa
copie c'était une décision attendue car
de bon sens juge des référés liberté
puisque aucune activité n'avait été
soumise à une limitation indépendamment
des superficies des des lieux d'accueil
c'est ce que dit conseil d'état c'est le
mot disproportionnée au regard des de la
condition des enjeux de santé publique
exactement ça veut dire que vous les
églises ou ou tout autre lieu de culte
d'ailleurs qui sont concernés aussi par
cette jauge ne sont pas des lieux de
contamination contrairement à ce qu'a
dit le premier ministre pas du tout les
évêques de france ont bien stipulé que
les les mesures étaient à être appliquée
pour lutter contre les contaminations
éventuelles et la propagation du commis
de 19 les évêques de france ont invité à
observer les décisions de l'état tout en
se portant devant le juge des référé
liberté devant une mesure qui défiait le
bon sens dans une chapelle de 20
personnes m 30 personnes c'est c'est
absolument contradictoire avec ses
précautions de responsabilité humaine
citoyenne des chrétiennes mais m trente
personnes dans une cathédrale clients il
dispose de 1000 places c'est
complètement aberrant aussi donc cette
mesure est accueilli comme mesures de
bon sens et pas du tout comme la mise en
eau des nécessités de prophylaxie en
matière de contamination possible nous
parlera qu'aux vidéos
comment est ce qu'on a pu arriver à une
telle absurdité n y at il pas eu des
consultations avec le premier ministre
avant d'imposer cette mesure
deux choses je crois que la première
chose et je le disais une question de
bon sens et je
que ceux qui ont préparé cette mesure et
de jauge à 30 personnes soit jamais
rentré dans des églises chapelles
cathédrale où bat j deuxième chose nous
constatons une un des shows le dialogue
ait des débats entre les différentes
instances notamment l'état et la
représentation de l'église catholique en
france et ses taux au dialogue ouvert et
sensée et aux débats que les évêques de
france appellent de façon à ne pas avoir
à recourir à la voie judiciaire
mais mes pouvoir régler dans le dialogue
et le débat
ces questions puisque il est assez rare
de voir les effectivement cette
communauté catholique protester contre
le gouvernement ce soir le premier
ministre reçoit lé représentant des
évêques de france
est ce que vous savez ce qui s'est dit
et vers quoi s'achemine-t-on alors la
situation dans les baies de france et
chez les catholiques de france des plus
contrastés de ce que l'on dit ne s'agit
pas d'une forte opposition unanime
il ya effectivement une revendication
liée à la nécessité est fondamentale les
chrétiens sentent de pouvoir vivre et
non pas à citer vivent là mais c'est le
mystère de l'eucharistie
maintenant je ne peux pas vous dire
c'est que les deux premiers ministres et
la représentation des évêques de france
vont ils se sont dit effectivement il y
aura un communiqué probablement à la
fois du premier ministre et de la
conférence des évêques de france
l issue de cette réunion nous espérons
une jauge limitée non pas 30 personnes
mais à 30 % de l'occupation des locaux
d'autant que nous nous volume religieux
sont largement imposés alors c'est une
période où il y aura je les imagine
beaucoup de fidèles puisque ce week-end
les catholiques fait le premier week-end
de l'avent
c'était essentiel pour vous justement à
cette période que ce cette jauge soit
levé que ces restrictions soient levés
il ya la période
nous entrons dans la nouvelle année
liturgique et dans le temps de l'avent
qui nous prépare au muscat de noël
c'est donc un itinéraire fondamentale
spirituelle et sociale des chrétiens car
les chrétiens ne vivent pas la fois
isolé de manière individuelle mais en
communauté dans l'église ça c'est un
premier point
deuxièmement il y à ce que l'état doit
garantir au titre de la loi du 9
décembre 1905 de séparation des églises
et de l'état et la liberté de l'exercice
des cultes
j'ai cependant nous concourons bien je
vous en prie finissait nous comprenons
bien que dans le cadre la pandémie que
du bon il y ait des mesures ils soient
demandés et les évêques de france ont
d'ailleurs proposé un protocole
sanitaire pour la réouverture au culte
dans une jauge raisonnable vous passez
exigeant dernière question très court
legault le conseil d'état a parlé d'une
atteinte grave à la liberté de culte
cette question d'atteinte aux libertés
et hautement à la une de l'actualité
vous êtes d'accord avec ce constat le
président de la république en 2018
devant la conférence des évêques de
france a déclaré que le lien entre
l'église et l'état s'étaient détériorées
et qu'il convenait de le réparer un
dialogue en vérité nous espérons
profondément cette réparation du lien
entre l'église catholique et l'état à
plus d'un titre
nous venons de vivre dans la basilique
notre-dame à un attentat cette attente a
bien montré combien l'église catholique
très partie 2
de la nation et combien elle est aussi
visée comme partie intégrante de sa
culture de son histoire
et donc c'est la liberté fondamentale
d'exercice des cultes
c'est partie de nos droits issues de la
constitution de la liberté de conscience
de la personne humaine qui convient
aussi une dimension spirituelle lui nier
serait était contradictoire avec ce
qu'est la france
ces principes merci beaucoup filles
passent au d'avoir répondu ce soir en
direct à nos questions sur rt france et
hier les magasins dits non essentiels
ont pu rouvrir en france après un mois
de fermeture forcée à cause de la crise
sanitaire ouverture donc de nouveau
autorisée mais avec un protocole
sanitaire renforcée en belgique ces
commerces pourront rouvrir mardi
prochain alors comment vivent les belges
eux ces restrictions de l'autre côté de
la frontière
voyez ce reportage de raphaël blonde
amour et walid bennani des images d'une
île presque déserte des rideaux encore
fermée plus que quelques heures avant
une réouverture des commerces non
essentiels très attendu les commerces
belge désemparé perdu à l'issue de ce
deuxième confinement le premier
confinement on était vu comme un magasin
non essentiel donc qu elles nous ont
fermé durant
deux mois là ils nous ont fermé
pendant quatre jours et après on a eu un
téléphone qui nous disait qu'on pouvait
ouvrir donc pour nos clients s'étaient
pas très clair il ya beaucoup de clients
français qui pensait aussi que les
frontières étaient fermées comme la
première fois mais ce n'est pas le cas
mais les temps ne m'a rien donné
alors je dois dire mont blanc lors des
mondiaux au maire de
vendre un peu à ma fenêtre depuis à moi
et puis m'a autorisé autorisé de le
faire parce que je suis tout ça l'est
aussi
quarante trois ans que j'habite ici et
et siala commerce délivrance prévu donc
ce mardi 1er décembre mais avec des
contraintes notamment en shopping qui
devra se faire seul est limité trente
minutes
pour le gouvernement il ne doit pas
s'agir d'un shopping de détente en
entendant cette réouverture
la tentation était grande ce week end et
à la proche de noël de traverser la
frontière
l'e commerce français ayant rouvert
depuis samedi
je pense que ça va paraître énorme non
plus parce qu'ils disent tellement dans
l'est dans le télé ici parler en france
palais en hollande
je suis déjà longtemps ici dans 36 ans
j'appelle ma clientèle donc mais c'est
quand même dur hein quand le malheur des
uns fait le petit bonheur des autres
côté français certains gérants se
félicite de cette aubaine
tu as bien marché a bien fonctionné il
ya eu 2 du passage parce qu'il ya le
marché pas loin donc il ya eu des gens
qui sont venus et comment acheter
d'électroménager ce matin ils ont
commencé à acheter des jouets de noël la
14 heures quand j'ai ouvert il ya eu des
clients aussi pour les jouets de noël
on a eu de la chance parce que nous en
tant que professionnel qu'on avait le
droit donc de circuler et donc j'ai dû
livrer et pas mal donc en belgique ça
nous a ramené qu'à main mais une
clientèle potentielle
on a du travail quand même allez je
dirais facilement entre 25 et 30% sur
une cliente est donc question le belge
en ce temps de crise sanitaire et malgré
la concurrence la solidarité est aussi
palpable
j'avoue qu'on n'ouvre mais on a quand
même un gros pincement encore on pense
vraiment énormément à eux parce qu'on se
met dans leur lave et qu on se fait dans
leur situation est franchement c'est
vrai que il n'ya rien à comprendre en
fait puisque il franchit cela il
traverse la rue ils sont chez nous ils
peuvent rentrer dans le magasin donc eu
ce pas logique
selon la principale fédération belge du
commerce et des services
chaque jour de fermeture représente une
perte de 100 millions d'euros
à la une de l'actualité cette semaine
donald trump qui a fait un pas de plus
vers l'acceptation de la victoire de joe
biden il quittera la maison blanche si
le collège électoral le confirme la cour
suprême de pennsylvanie a rejeté hier
une nouvelle plainte du président
américain est là mais jared anthony
blinken et l'un des principaux
conseillers de joe biden en matière de
politique étrangère à l'instar du
président élu le francophone et
francophile de 58 ans souhaite que les
états unis retrouvent leur place dans le
concert des nations
le futur chef de la diplomatie
américaine aura du pain sur la planche
après l'abandon successifs par
l'administration trunk d'alliance et
d'accords internationaux
anthony blinken devrait notamment
empêché la sortie des états unis de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé
ressuciter l'accord sur le nucléaire
iranien et rejoindre l'accord de paris
sur le climat à l'accord sur le climat
que john kerry lui-même avait négocié en
décembre 2015 alors chef de la
diplomatie
signe de l'importance que porte joe
biden à ce dossier
john kerry sera l'émissaire spécial du
président élu pour le climat l'ancien
secrétaire d'état de barack obama âgé de
76 ans siégera au conseil de sécurité
nationale de la maison blanche
et c'est bien la première fois qu'un de
ses membres est spécifiquement chargés
des questions climatiques
aux etats unis alejandro mayorkas ce est
né à la havane en 1959
ce fils de réfugiés anticastriste sera
le premier hispanique a dirigé le
ministère de la sécurité intérieure aux
états unis
un département qui supervise notamment
les questions d'immigration
alejandro mayorkas ce ancien procureur
fédéral connaît bien cette
administration dont il fut ministre
adjoint de 2013 à 2016
le président élu a également sélectionné
avril heinz pour prendre la tête de la
direction du renseignement national un
poste uniquement occupés par des hommes
jusqu'ici avril à 51 ans ancienne
directrice adjointe de la cia sera la
femme la plus haut placée dans la
communauté du renseignement
enfin l'afro américaine linda thomass
greenfield deviendra de son côté
ambassadrice à l'onu
la diplomate chevronné de 68 ans fut
entre autres secrétaire d'état adjointe
pour l'afrique est ambassadrice au
libéria et l'essentiel pour les
républicains c'est de conserver le
scénar c'est l'analyse de douglas y est
professeur de droit et spécialiste de
sciences politiques américaines
maintenant l'enjeu pour le crack et
républicaine au niveau national c'est le
seul 1 il y a deux sièges dans le jour j
qui sont dangereux il est en élection
spéciale et tout le parti républicain
savent que centre ans et risque de
perdre ses sièges au sénat et donc le
majorité donc oui paul en ce temps là
magie de données offrant avec les
lecteurs et pop les cas d'effacement son
base est assez importante que
l'établissement républicains continuent
à le soutenir
très peu de républicains ont dû avouer
qu'il a perdu les élections
mais si les républicains m
le géologie et le sénat là on va voir
glissement rejet dans leur second tour
des élections municipales au brésil le
pays qui élit les maires et les
conseillers municipaux de 57 villes des
résultats très attendus car il s'agit du
premier scrutin depuis l'arrivée de ryan
bel small sonar ou à la tête du pays un
président en mauvaise posture après le
fiasco de son camp au premier tour voyez
ce qu'en disent ses électeurs brésiliens
à la sortie des bureaux de vote pour
tout docteur avec tout ce qui se passe
le vote devient encore plus important
qu'il ne l'était déjà parce que malgré
la pandémie voter en ce moment au brésil
est un acte très important pour nous
afin de faire entendre notre voix face à
tout ce qui se passe nous avons besoin
d'un candidat qui valorise la santé qui
est avec l'agent et qui se soucie de la
situation sanitaire dans ce pays et
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
votre fidélité sur notre antenne l'info
est aussi retrouver sur notre site
internet
rt france point tv quant à nous on se
retrouve dans 30 minutes
restez avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]
le 4 octobre dernier la nouvelle
calédonie à voter sur son avenir avec ou
sans la france et pour la deuxième fois
de nom à l'indépendance l'a emporté avec
53,26 % alors qu'il était à 56,4 au
premier vingt après le troisième
référendum en 2022
le maintien dans la france où
l'indépendance déboucheront forcément
retour des troubles importants créé par
les pertes en eau